[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ولد الشيخ علي يوسف في موزمبيق وانتقل الى
مالاوي للعيش في منطقه منغوتشي المسلمه
وفيها التحق بعدد من المدارس الاسلاميه
لتعلم اللغه العربيه وحفظ القران الكريم
ورغم الظروف القاسيه والحروب الاهليه التي
عاصفت ببلاده اصر على طلب الرزق وتلقي
العلوم الشرعيه وهذا ما دفعه الى الهجره
الى جنوب افريقيا حيث يعمل مدرسا للقران
الكريم
تربيت في منطقه منغوتشي وان كنت لم ولد في
في
والدي من منغوتشي من ملاوي ولكن
امي من زيمبابوي امي من زمبابه فانا ولدت
في زيمبابوي ثم الوالد انتقل من زمبابوي
الى دوله مالاوي
فتربيت في ملاوي
درست القران من بدايتها من منطقه منغوتي
مع
شيخي لا انساه الى اليوم رحمه الله اسمه
عوف هو الذي درسني بدايه الف باء تاء ثاء
هكذا الى ان استطعت ان اقرا كلمتين ثلاثه
كلمات ايه وقران ثم بعد ذلك
انتقلت الى مدرسه في نفسها في كان مدرسه
تعلم ليس فقط القران لكن العلوم الدينيه
كلها فجلست هناك لسنه واحده فقط ثم بعد
ذلك
انتقلت الى مدينه
يسمونها مدينه ممكن يقولون عاصمه الاقتصاد
في ملاوي هناك عاصمه الدوله ديلونجى
وعاصمه
الاقتصادي يسمونه بلنتير
وهناك مدرسه
اسس
بواسطه
المؤسسون هم لجنه مسلمه افريقيا
بدعم من اللجنه
لكن تاسيس هذه المدرسه
بدات بزياره
الدكتور عبد الرحمن سميت رحمه الله بزياره
ملاوي لما زار ملاوي ثم بعد ذلك بدا
الدعوه في ملاوي ثم اسسوا هذه المدرسه
فانا ممنغوتي انتقلت اخذوني من منغوتي الى
هذه المدرسه
الشيخ
محمد صديق معاذ الندوي
هو شيخي
وهو المدير لهذه المدرسه
جاء الى منغوتشي يختبر الطلاب الصغار
مستعدين
للدراسه القران والعلوم الدينيه
فانا بفضل الله كنت
من ضمن الذين
اختاروهم
ليستمروا في دراسه القران والدين في هذه
المدرسه معهد يسمونها معهد ابي بكر الصديق
رضي الله عنه في بلنته هذه المدرسه في
بلنته فدرست هناك القران والدين وفي نفس
الوقت الدراسه كلها ليس فقط دراسه الدين
ولكن الدراسه العصريه كمان العلوم
والرياضيات وهذه الامور كلها ثم بعد ذلك
في سنه 87
انتقلت من بلنتيره ثم ذهبت الى السودان
في الخرطوم
كان هناك مركز الان هي جامعه لكن في
البدايه كان المركز الاسلامي لافريقي
كانوا يسمونه المركز الاسلامي الافريقي
فهذه من هذا المركز من من المراكز التي
نشر الدين كمن في افريقيا لان اكثر الناس
فارقه كلهم درسوا كثير منهم درسوا في هذا
المركز الان صارت جامعه يسمونها الجامعه
العالميه الافريقيه
جلست هناك لسنتين درست القران والدين
والعلوم الاخرى كمان
ثم بعد السنتين انتقلت الى السعوديه
في الجامعه الاسلاميه بالمدينه المنوره
درست هناك لست سنوات سنتين في المعهد
الثانويه
لاني كنت قد قملت سنه واحده للثانويه في
السودان ثم انتقلت الى السعوديه فدخلت سنه
ثانيه للثانويه والثالثه ثم بعد ذلك
التحقت بكليه الشريعه في الجامعه
الاسلاميه
اربع سنوات فتخرجت سنه 1994
يعني سنه 1014
هجري والله انا بنفسي لا لا اعتبر نفسي من
من القراء بس درست القران
حفظت شيئا من القران لكن لا اعتبر نفسي من
القرى فلذلك بعض الناس قلناه قارئ لكن انا
لست لست لست تخصصي ليس في الله
وان كنت من الحفاظ لكن
تخصصي ليست في القران ما تخصصت في
القراءات مثل الشيخ
بنيامين وجماعه الاخوه الذين شغلهم عملهم
في القران دائما
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
يا
ايها الذين امنوا اتقوا الله
وقولوا قولا
سديدا
يصلح لكم
اعمالكم ويغفر لكم
ذنوبكم
ومن يطع الله ورسوله فقد فاز فوزا عظيما
انا عرضنا الامانه على السماوات
والارض
والجبال فابين
ابين ان
يحملنها
واشفقن منها
واشفقن منها وحملها
الانسان
انه كان ظلوما جهولا
ليعذب الله
المنافقين
والمنافقات
والمشركين والمشركات
ويتوب الله على المؤمنين
والمؤمنات
وكان الله
غفورا رحيما
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اتاح التطور الاقتصاد الذي تعيشه جنوب
افريقيا وانتشار المساجد في مختلف مدنها
وقراها مع تعايش للافارقه والاسيويين اتاح
لعدد كبير من القراء والحفظ من دول الشرق
الافريقيه الانتقال والعيش ومن بينهم
الشيخ علي يوسف الذي يقبل على دروسه
العشرات من الافارقه
ملاوي تقع في وسط الشرق افريقيا
نقول هكذا وسط شرق افريقيا ملاوي
وعلى الحدود الشماليه التنزانيه والحدود
الجنوبيه
والشرقيه وبعض الغربيه كمن دوله موزمبيق
من الغرب كمان قليلا فيه دوله دوله
محاط بهذه الدول موزمبيق
زامبيا وتنزانيا
فمن لا يعرف
يستطيع بهذا يعرف وين ملاوي فهي دوله
صغيره
نسمه تقريبا
الان 18 مليون تقريبا نعم
وعدد المسلمين ما يقارب الى خمسين بالمئه
مسلمون الانشطه الدعويه وعن الاسلام ما
شاء الله في ملاوي
ناس يعملون في الدعوه
ودوله مالاوي لانها
معروفه بكونها انها هي التي نشرت كثيرا
الاسلام في الدول الجنوب الافريقي
لذلك لو ذهبت الى مثلا جنوب افريقيا
تبحث عن المسلمين في جنون افريقيا اكثرهم
غير الاخوه اللي اتوا هنا منذ 300 سنه من
السود خاصه من السودان اكثر هموم
المراويون الموجودين هنا في جنوب افريقيا
وليس فقط في جنوب افريقيا حتى لو ذهبت الى
دوله بوتانا او الى دوله زامبيا ولايه
دوله زيمبابوي اكثر من تجد من هناك مسلمون
هم الذين هاجروا من ملاوي الى هذه الدول
ويعملون هناك فترى ام المسلمون الكثيرون
فعندهم نشاطات ما شاء الله الحمد لله لهم
نشاط دعويه
يعني كبير في هذه الدول
انتقالي الى جنوب افريقيا انا انتقلت هنا
طلبا للعلم اتيت هنا الى جامعه جنوب
افريقيا ادرس الماجستير
كل شيء مقدر عندما اتيت هنا كنت اقول ادرس
وارجع الى مالاوي
لكن التقينا الاحبه هنا
يعني وظفون عمل لنعمل في الدعوه في
التدريس اللغه العربيه وفي التدريس
الدراسه الاسلاميه
فلذلك بقيت هنا في جنوب افريقيا لكن
انتقالي الى هناك كان للدراسه فكنت ادرس
في جامعه جنوب افريقيا في جامعه
درست هناك لثلاث سنوات ماجستير تخرجت
ثم
بدات بالعمل
الان ادرس في مدرسه اسلاميه ودرس اللغه
العربيه وفي نفس الوقت مسؤوله عن
من ضمن
المجلس التي
يعني تقوم
[موسيقى]
بتدريس اللغه العربيه في جنوب افريقيا
كلها جنوب افريقيا المسلمون ما شاء الله
هم ناس عندهم انشطه في الدعوه انشطه لذلك
عنده مدارس كثير مدارس للتدريس العلوم
القران تدريس الدراسات الاسلاميه ما شاء
الله عندهم
وان كانوا ينقصهم شيء واحد انهم الان فيه
التطور شويه في امور الدعوه انهم ما كان
هناك دعوه قويه لا سيما
للاخوه الاصليين من جنوب افريقيا الدعوه
كانت قليله الان ما شاء الله شويه يعني
فيه عمل الدعوه
للاخوه الذين
اصليون من جنوب افريقيا اصول الناس من
جنوب افريقيا من اعاني بذلك السن الاخوه
في جنوب افريقيا ففي دعوه الحمد لله
[موسيقى]
اعوذ بالله من الشيطان الرجيم بسم الله
الرحمن الرحيم
والنازعات غرقا
والناشطات نشطا
والسابحات سبحا
فالسابقات سبقا
فالمدبرات امرا يوم ترجف الراجفه
تتبعها الرادفه قلوب
يومئذ واجفه
ابصارها خاشعه
يقولون
ائنا
لمردودون في الحافره
ادا كنا عظاما نخره
قالوا تلك اذا
كره خاسره
فانما هي زجره واحده
فاذا
هم بالساهره
هل اتاك حديث موسى
اذ ناداه ربه
بالواد
المقدسه
اذهب الى فرعون
انه طغى
فقل هل لك الى ان تزكى
واهديك الى ربك فتخشى
فارعه الايه الكبرى
فكذب وعصى ثم
ادبر يسعى
فحشر فنادى
فقال انا ربكم الاعلى
فاخذه الله
نكال الاخره والاولى
ان في ذلك
لعبره
لمن يخشى
اجواء رمضان في جنوب افريقيا جميله جدا
لانها يعني جو القران
فالانسان
الى مناطق المسلمين لاسماء الى القران
ناسيه ماذا التراويح فهي يعني ايام
ما رايتها من حتى من الدول العربيه
في المساجد ما شاء الله لكن هنا في جنوب
افريقيا ليس فقط المساجد الجو يكون جو
قران في البيوت وفي الناس عندهم يعني
مصليات اماكن كثيره للحفاظ حتى
يتمرنوا في في قراءه القران
فيكون الجو يكون جو جو القران في رمضان
يعني الانسان يعرف انه اذا اذا جاء جنوب
افريقيا في ايام رمضان يعرف ان هذا شهر
القران انه شهر القران فكل واحد يعني
يعني يكون مرتبط بالقران
ما عندي انشطه خاصه في رمضان ما عدا
لاني مسؤول
قسم التحفيظ القران فانشطه يكون اكثر في
يعني ترغيب الناس في القران
والقاء محاضرات عن القران وهذه من الانشطه
التي نقوم بها في شهر رمضان والقاء الخطب
وكلمات محاضرات
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]